- Podcast station, what is good?
A very special episode today.
I believe this man will have
no need for an introduction.
We have Mark Zuckerberg.
I have to start practicing this, Mark.
I've been in a bunch of
meetings saying Meta,
just a lot of practice.
You really threw me for a curve ball.
- Yeah, I'm still getting used to it too.
- So obviously Mark is at the helm
and the head of Meta
and I'm really excited
to be talking to him
because I really want to
get into the metaverse
and the Web 3.0 world.
Obviously so much of
this community is aware
of my involvement in the NFT space.
And it's funny on the way
here I realized, oh my God,
this interview is going to
go similar to the Joe Namath
interview I had for all
my sports nerd friends
that listen to this podcast.
When I had Namath on,
I literally asked him 14
questions that were so left field
compared to the normal
Joe Namath questions.
For example, I asked him about why
we lost the AFC championship game
and didn't go to Super Bowl IV
instead of talking about Super Bowl III.
And I realize that's
what's going to happen here
because I have so many very
selfish questions for Mark
about this Web 3.0 world
that I'm going to be selfish
with my limited time with him.
So Mark, first of all,
it's good to see you.
And how are you?
- It's good to see you too.
It's been a while since we've
done something like this,
but I'm glad to get a chance to do it.
There's a lot of exciting
stuff going on right now.
You know the reason why we come to you
is because you do ask good questions.
So let's go for it.
I'm curious what you got for me.
- So, Mark, I think what's really funny
in the Meta, pun intended,
it's NFT NYC right now.
And I was saying to AJ and Kevin Rose,
bunch of the old Web 2.0 friends,
how much this feels like the
early South by Southwest days.
And obviously, one of the
first times we sat down
was after your keynote at South
by just jamming ,talking about the space.
And I remember the conversation vividly
'cause I have a solid memory
and 'cause a lot of the
things we talked about
about where this was
all going was the topic.
And many of these things played out.
As somebody that I feel has always had
a disproportionate understanding of
communication, consumer, human behavior,
give me your first hot take.
I know you've had this big
announcement the other day.
What is your macro thesis
of the Web 3.0 place
we're going, whether it's
the metaverse, the NFT stuff,
like what are we on the precipice of
and how similar is it to the time
where right before Facebook was launched?
- Yeah, so the metaverse to me today
feels like the next frontier
in social connection
in much the same way that
social networking did
when I was getting started back in 2004.
That's a big reason why we
wanted to change the brand
of the company is that
today I think most people
think about us as a social media company,
but in our DNA, we're a technology company
that builds all kinds
of different technology
to help people connect
and tries to advance human connection.
And of course, social media
is one important part of that.
But I think increasingly
it's going to be about
building platforms and experiences
that deliver the sense of presence.
Like you're right there
with another person.
There's, of course, all the
virtual and augmented reality
parts of that.
And there's the hardware.
And I'm really excited about that.
The work that we've been working on that
for seven years now at this point.
So that's making a lot of progress.
But I think some of the experiences
are starting to come together too.
We've started to release
Horizon and Workrooms
and some of these experiences
where you can feel like
you're present with someone in a place.
It's just pretty crazy to
see how that's taking off.
It's not just games,
games I think is the
natural starting point.
But beyond that, we're
starting to see at this point
that social interaction
and just hanging out
is starting to become the biggest way
that people spend time on these platforms.
That kind of makes sense and
fits with my experience so far.
- Mark, when you say these platforms,
are you speaking
specifically in the behaviors
seen of people in Oculus?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Let's actually go right there
because you said something in there
and I hope the audience is listening.
Seven years.
I remember like yesterday
you, Meta, acquiring Oculus.
- Always tough to know how to
refer to it in the past tense.
- I'm gonna, I'm gonna use
both, so stick with me.
The Oculus purchase was really interesting
because the Instagram purchase,
which I was really kind of caught up in
because of some of the
content I was making,
the attempt on Snap,
all of those made a ton of sense
because you were executing on the thing
that I've always thought you had,
which is where's the current attention?
How do we play within that space?
The Oculus one was weird for me
because I was like, oh, that's far away.
Why did he do that?
Seven years in metaverse,
people are just now
starting to kind of get going.
What was the thinking of that?
Like, why'd you do that?
- Well, I mean, a lot of it is just that
we spend most of our
days building social apps
that you use on a little phone.
And you know, as powerful as that is,
you have your phone with you all the time,
it's also pretty limiting.
You're not delivering an experience
where you can really feel like
you're with another person.
And in a lot of ways,
that's sort of the ultimate dream
of building these digital
social experiences
is actually being able to make
it so that people can feel
like they're there together
and doing something together
and then kind of collaborating.
And no technology that we
have today can deliver that.
So we've seen this progression where,
when I started the company, it was people,
primarily the internet,
was primarily about text.
So people can turn text into a computer.
Then we got phones that had cameras.
So the internet became a
lot more visual and mobile.
And over the last few years,
internet connections have gotten
a lot better for everyone.
So video is really the primary way
that we share experiences.
So you have this progression
from text to photos to videos,
connection and expressing ourselves
keeps on getting more
natural and immersive,
but that's not the end of the line.
There's going to be something after video
and it's going to be much more immersive
and it's going to be
something that we can do
throughout the day.
So you'll have virtual reality
for when you want to go
into a really immersive zone,
you'll have augmented
reality to have holograms,
so you can imagine a
version of this conversation
three or five years from now
where instead of doing this
over video, you're a hologram
here in my living room,
or I'm a hologram in your living room.
And that's going to be pretty wild.
- On that point, I want to jump into that.
Do you think, and you
know I've watched you talk
in the past that I know
how I communicate this
because it's always so challenging.
Is your intuition that it is
three to five years from now
that the tech between 5G,
which was an important step
between some of the stuff
you're doing and other people,
other companies and
entrepreneurs are doing,
do you think we can actually...
I saw something I think in my feed
where you were fencing with somebody
as part of the announcement,
which looked wild 'cause it was on some
Obi-Wan Kenobi shit.
Like right?
I was like, oh my God, it's happening!`
Is that, do you think three
to five is a solid guess?
Is that optimistic?
Talk to me about that.
- I think you want to break it down to
there's the virtual reality side
and the augmented reality side.
VR is here.
I think Quest was really the form factor
that was necessary to make it mainstream.
Quest Two I think was a
meaningful step beyond that
and is kind of the first mainstream hit
that we've had so many millions of that...
- I don't know what you're
allowed to share or not.
So if you don't feel
comfortable, tell me you can't.
Is there public...
I'm just trying to learn how much...
- We don't have a public
number yet, but it's...
What I can say is it's many millions
and it's multiple times
more than Quest One,
which was sort of the form
factor we felt like we needed.
So that'll keep on improving
and we'll keep on shipping
new versions of that.
So there were a lot of
great experiences there
and it's been really cool
to see the use cases there
broaden out from games to social
to now having things around fitness.
- It's a lot of fitness,
that caught my radar,
that there was a lot more
people paying for fitness apps
in Quest than I had any clue of.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean, well think about it.
It's kind of like the Peloton model where
instead of having a bike or a treadmill,
you just have your $300 headset
and you can take it with
you anywhere you want.
You can do boxing or dancing
or different kinds of cardio.
It's pretty awesome.
So I think that that'll go for awhile
and get extended a lot.
So there all these
different use cases in VR.
When you're talking
about the fencing video
that I showed with Lee
Kiefer in the hologram,
that, you're going to need
augmented reality glasses.
And that's a harder problem because
first, you're inventing a
completely new optical stack.
So you're not just using normal screens
and kind of building an
architecture around that,
which is how virtual reality
has sort of worked to date.
You need to design a projector
and a set of wave guides
so that way you can have
glasses that look normal,
you can see through them.
There's a lot of interesting
science and engineering there,
but for augmented reality,
if you're going to wear
it throughout the day,
it's just a lot more
important that the form factor
is like normal looking glasses.
I mean, virtual reality you
can do in your living room.
- Do you think, I'm sorry to interrupt,
do you think by the time it hits scale
that there's a chance that
this is a contact lens game,
not a cumbersome overlay,
like a glasses or a thick...
what's your take on that?
Is that too hard?
- I mean, some people are working on that.
I think that that's quite a
bit further off just because,
think about it.
It's like whatever is projecting the image
needs to have an internet connection.
It needs to be powered.
I've seen some people have
a model of a contact lens
that has a little projector
that's sort of like
in front of your pupil and your blind spot
and it can project something in,
but then how are you
going to have that sync
with the whole rest of the internet
and be powered throughout the day?
- What if I swallowed a 5G pill?
- I don't know, let's
say 20 years from now.
I think that that might be a thing.
But AR glasses,
I think we're going to start
seeing things that look like
normal looking glasses, but
that can project holograms
into the world within the next five years.
I think that's a somewhat
conservative estimate.
- Did Pokemon Go, going
back five years ironically,
was that something you watched carefully?
Because I was like, holy
shit, this is now happening.
People are pulling off on this highway,
jumping into the woods to find a Pikachu.
I would have lost...
I'm pretty good at this game too,
but I would have lost this bet,
which was after that was such
a smash hit through the phone,
the fact that we're here five years later
and there has not been another significant
AR phone execution of that scale,
surprising to me.
What's your take on that?
- Well, I think Pokemon
Go, it was interesting
and it's a real hit and it is phenomenon,
I consider it to be more
of a location-based game
than an augmented reality game.
The fact that it shows that you look at it
through your camera,
I think is somewhat incidental.
I think the core mechanic is
that you're going to a place.
And so you can do that with
augmented reality or not,
but there is certainly is
going to be a whole class
of experiences that are like that.
But in terms of things that really
kind of augment reality,
I think you have filters,
face filters, different effects like that,
like what you see in
Instagram and Snapchat.
I think that that's a real thing
that I think is real augmented reality.
And certainly I think that
there's going to be a lot more
opportunity there once you get
to these real looking glasses
that can put holograms in the world.
So yeah, I would hope that
by the middle of this decade,
we can have something that's
sort of like that fencing clip
that I showed.
Now, the other issue on
that is you need haptics.
That way, when your sword
hits the hologram sword,
you get a sense of feeling from that.
So that's a whole interesting
other area of research,
and I'm not sure exactly
where that will be
by the middle of this decade,
but that's another thing
that we're working on
because it's clearly an important part
of the whole picture is
you need to be able to,
whether you're playing basketball
or giving someone a high five
or shaking their hand,
you want to be able to get
a sense of pressure back.
That, I think, is just going
to be an important part
of the whole thing too.
- Mark, when you make a move like this
to get the organization
to this next place,
I assume, 'cause I think
about when I do things,
oftentimes it's more
for my team internally
than for the world.
Like if they don't understand
where I'm trying to
take Veyner or my stuff,
then I've got no shot.
Was that a thought about
this in a lot of ways?
Like, Hey, I got to make sure,
'cause you're a massive company now.
Is this like, I need to
give everybody a north star
internally of like, look, no,
no, this is what we're doing.
It's not just refining the
algo or a filter on Insta
or something of that nature.
- Yeah, you get this,
'cause you're running a company here
and a lot of this is really
just about making sure
that our team knows what we're doing.
Running a company is about
setting prioritization
and principles for where you want to go.
And I do think that it's
the case that a lot of times
the most effective way to
communicate to the organization
a level of commitment to something
is to go say it externally,
because now people know
that you're serious.
So we've been talking about
this internally for many years.
We've been working on these
VR devices for seven years.
We've just sort of steadily
ramped up the investment
to the point where now, in 2021,
where we're investing $10 billion,
more than $10 billion in this.
It's still not the biggest
part of what we do,
but it's very meaningful.
I think that you'd be hard pressed
to find any other organization
that cares as much
about this and is putting
as much energy into building
all these different parts of the future.
And what I think you get for that
is that Meta has become the premier place
that if you care about these problems,
you want to go work on them.
So whether that's VR,
we're building the best device.
AR, I think we're the furthest ahead
in terms of actually building
the consumer glass form factor
and all the different
research around that.
You mentioned any of the
other problems around that,
whether it's haptics or
a lot of the software
parts of this, where people can interact.
We're going to be the
place where you can build
all these different parts
of the metaverse experience
and then also weave them
into Facebook and Instagram
and WhatsApp.
That's going to be pretty wild.
- You said something that
really caught my attention.
Obviously the far majority of people,
almost everybody who's listening to this
that runs a company,
is not going to be running
a company of your scale.
But what you said there
was not only for your team,
but did I hear the undertone
there of the fact that
you put out such a public
commitment to this,
you see as a recruiting vehicle
to the best engineers in
the game in this space?
- Yeah. Well, look.
I just think that when you plant a flag
and say that you're gonna go do something,
you get haters and criticisms,
you also get the people who
actually care about that thing
and want to make it happen
are attracted to the people
who I think have the courage to go say,
I'm gonna go make this happen
even though it's really far off.
So I think that all of these things are,
there are pros and cons to them,
and there's a lot of complexity to manage,
but I think that this is true
no matter what size organization you're at
is that having the
willingness to just go say,
Hey, here's what I want to go build,
I think certainly creates
the self-selection dynamic,
where when you say here's who
I am and what I want to go do,
then you get people
who want to share that.
And what I've found in my career
is that it's better to
not be timid about that
and to not pretend that you're
something that you're not
to try to appease critics.
The more that you can just
be honest to who you are
and what you want to go do,
I think you'll kind of
get the right people
to join your team.
You'll get the right investors,
you'll get the right partners.
And I think that that's kind
of how you move forward.
- Talk to me now, I'm going crazy selfish.
I referenced you and the
company a ton in my content
over the last decade as my macro thesis,
understand where the attention
is, it matters so much.
And I often reference your M&A behavior.
Can you just give me, because
I want to know for myself,
the insight on the Instagram
deal, the WhatsApp deal,
I'm going to leave Oculus off,
because that was like, I
want to maybe come back
to it in a little bit given
the macro metaverse convo,
but specifically Instagram and WhatsApp,
which I thought were
really of the moment deals.
I don't know if the corporation
acknowledges the attempt towards Snapchat.
It was well talked about,
I don't know the truth or not truth to it,
when I heard it or when it
was reported, I was like,
there he is again.
He's a hundred percent right.
He's on it again.
TikTok must've been potentially
a very different thing,
given they're China-based,
the complications...
I'll be very honest.
every day when I saw
Musical.ly way back, I'm like,
Facebook's gonna make a play.
A, am I right
that is a big tenor of how you guys
have looked at the world?
B, what's that about?
- Yeah.
So there are a lot of different
of these kind of core social interactions
that people have in these apps
that the different apps
have invented over time.
And I'm proud that that we've
invented a bunch of them,
going back to some of
the core dynamics around
being able to communicate
with people in your college,
we were the first that built newsfeed,
the core social API work early on...
- By way, on the record
for the youngsters,
I apologize.
By the way, for all the
youngsters listening right now,
when Facebook changed from
you going to somebody's wall
and leaving a comment, to this newsfeed,
it was fucking carnage.
The number one page or group
or whatever you guys called it
back then was bringing
back the wall or whatever.
Mark, can you speak to that real quick?
Just go back to your young, young days,
like when you guys made that move,
the community within,
nobody was even paying attention to you
in the mainstream and all that stuff now.
Within the world, immediately
people lost their mind.
And now that is the core
way every social network
was built in.
- Yeah. I mean, look,
sometimes when you invent
these things, they can be disruptive.
And I think you need
to have the commitment
to see it through.
But going back to your point about
some of these other companies,
it's like there was a
kernel with Instagram
and with WhatsApp and also with companies
like Snapchat, I think
that they created something
that I think is really
special and is awesome.
I just looked at that and I
was like, all right, okay.
There is something,
I think people often tend
to look at these social apps
and think that they're
frivolous, early on,
and they think that they're like
these dynamics aren't important.
Oh, it's filtered photos or
oh, it's disappearing photos
or whatever it is.
- Or it's only for college kids.
- Yeah, when we had that,
through our IPO and after
when we were having a lot
of business struggles,
but I kind of looked at
those and I was like,
Hey, I think that there's
something that's important here.
I think the world is probably
underestimating this.
And I also think that we
have the skills as a company
to go grow these things
to reach more than a billion
people around the world.
And because we'd done that with the core
Facebook experience.
And I think that there's two skills there,
there's sort of the building
the social experience
and then there's the
helping to ramp up a network
around that.
And that I think is
also a core competence.
I don't know what would
have happened with Instagram
if we hadn't bought it.
I don't think it's guaranteed
that it would have grown
to be as big as it is.
- Should I assume,
'cause I'm a nerd when it comes to
watching business behavior,
that much like what you're
doing with metaverse now,
which I think is the macro move of that,
and that in between now
and that scaled world,
the companies that have
the kernels that do best
in the attention graph, whether
that's in the metaverse,
video, picture, that will
always be a core focus.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think that that's a key
thing with this rebrand to Meta
is it's not like now we're
not focused on social media.
That's going to be the bread
and butter of what we do.
That's the core thing.
And our work to build the metaverse
encompasses both building
social experiences
and building these future
platforms like VR and AR.
It's gotta be both.
We have to weave all of
these new technologies
through these social apps,
'cause you want to be able
to jump into the metaverse
and a 3D experience from
your Instagram feed.
So you see your friend at a concert,
we showed this as part of
the keynote presentation,
and just dive in and maybe
be a hologram at the concert.
But a lot of the discovery around that
is going to happen through
the core social platforms.
So yeah, that's gonna
continue to be a focus.
We're going to keep on focusing
on growing and building apps
and adding more social
mechanics around that.
I think there's a lot
more to invent there.
And then I think that there's
this next set of platforms,
where one of the things that I reflect on
a lot is that social media kind of grew up
with the smartphone.
Facebook, I started it in 2004.
I think Apple was probably
already working on
their iPhone designed by then.
It came out in 2007.
We didn't really get to shape
what the smartphone was.
We built a lot of the most
used experiences for it,
but it grew at the same time.
And because of that,
I feel like the smartphone
sort of grew in a way
that it's somewhat limiting
in terms of the type
of social experiences that you could have.
I feel like there's a lot of things
that I would love to
build that we can't build
because we're kind of
constrained into this
little rectangle and policies
that some other company's set.
So that's part of, for me,
why I have so much
passionate about helping
to bring about this next platform shift
and accelerating it because
I think the sooner we get to
virtual and augmented reality, the better,
the more magical these social
experiences are gonna be.
And I just think our platforms
should be designed around people,
interacting with each other.
And that's like how we
process the world as people.
And that's just not how
phones are designed.
They're designed around apps today.
But I think, going back
to your first question
about NFTs and Web 3.0,
I think the atomic unit in the metaverse
is going to be about you and your stuff
and your friends and your connection.
So you're gonna have your avatar
and you're gonna have
your digital clothing
and your digital tools.
And unlike apps today
that are all designed
to be a little bit siloed,
and you have to do all this extra work
to get them to work Together,
in the metaverse, I think
it's going to be fundamentally
more interoperable where
your fundamental experiences
that you are embodied in your identity,
your digital avatar, all your stuff.
And I think as a user of this,
your natural expectation is going to be
that you can bring all your stuff
in between all these
experiences very seamlessly.
So I think that that's
going to be really exciting.
And I just want to help bring that about
as soon as possible.
- Mark, question I've
been dying to ask you.
When you first look, you probably given,
and maybe I'm making assumptions,
so you'll speak to it.
Obviously there was that
2017 wave with CryptoKitties
and we started seeing
that early wave of NFTs.
That was like the thing that,
Punks did not hit my radar,
but CryptoKitties did in '17.
And obviously now this
has been the year of NFTs,
the way we know them,
whether it's Bored Ape,
what I do with VeeFriends,
obviously Punks and Cool Cats,
many, many, many projects.
One of the reasons it was very easy for me
when I really dug in late last year
to believe in this was actually because of
Farmville on Facebook.
There was two things that
happened to me during that year.
Farmville on Facebook.
Oh my God, People are
buying these digital sheep
because they want the social
currency to show their friends
they're good at it.
And then Ze Frank.
I don't know if you remember Ze Frank.
- Yeah, uh huh.
Ze Franks was one of the
first video bloggers.
He had people buy virtual
ducks as little tip jars
and have their name hover over it.
And those were the first times I was like,
oh my God, people are going
to buy virtual things,
virtual currency.
In my book, Thank you Economy,
I talk a lot about virtual
currency in 2010, '11.
Was it natural for you to believe in
what's happening right now with NFTs
because of the things like Farmville
that happened on your platform?
- Well, I've always been
a pretty big believer
in virtual goods.
So I think from that perspective, yeah.
But I think a lot of the magic of NFTs
and a lot of the Web 3.0 work
is that it's designed in a way
to be fundamentally interoperable.
So I think that that's
going to be really important
because it will help break down the silos
between different apps and make it so that
all your stuff can be more portable
between these different experiences,
which I think increasingly is what people
are going to expect.
I think that that's going to be a big part
for creators of making it
really worth investing in
because if you're designing a digital good
for Farmville and it
only works within there,
then like, I dunno.
You get to the point
where most of the people
who are going to be building that...
- To your point, here
the world we live in now.
You're a young kid and you're
in Minecraft or Roblox,
you grow up and you
want to go to Fortnight.
All that money you
invested is stuck in there.
In the world that you're
talking about right now,
the Roblox and Minecraft of the future,
when you're done with that,
you're just gonna trade it
for your Fortnite stuff.
You're gonna trade the
Fortnite stuff or sell it.
It's all gonna be in that
one global ecosystem.
- Yeah, the analogy that
I like to think about is,
I like your Knicks hoodie,
but imagine if you bought a Jersey
and you could only use
it in the sports arena
where you bought it.
It's like that would be sort of lame
and it would reduce
the value of buying it.
Because who's gonna want to buy something
if they can only use it in that arena?
I mean, some people would,
but a fraction of the number of people
who would want to buy it
if they could use in all
these different places.
And then if the amount of
commerce is going to be less
than that's gonna attract fewer creators.
So I think having it be more interoperable
is going to be key to making
the whole thing so dynamic.
- What's interesting about that
in a much more interesting
human behavior way
is people will wear it, to
your point, it's limiting.
What's also interesting is the clout,
the equity, the social currency,
carries more weight from a
tribalism behavior standpoint
in Madison Square Garden,
which I'm looking at right now,
than it does outside,
though it has tremendous value outside.
What I'm incredibly interested
in is the following.
Obviously, I don't
remember if it was Twitter,
I think it was Twitter, who
did the blue check mark first,
The verification.
We've now lived through a
decade where verified accounts,
following counts, social
equity through visualization.
We've seen it with followers
and verified accounts,
The extremity of the NFT space
is going to be even greater
for what that means.
It's almost like our world
is all about to become
the fashion industry because
we communicate so much
through what we wear,
the digital version of
that is going to have
an incredible impact on society.
- Oh, totally.
I think if we're all
spending a lot more time
in the metaverse, then I
think we're going to care
a lot about our
representation of our identity
and we're going to want different outfits.
Maybe everyone except me,
I just wear the same thing.
- Did you steal that from Steve Jobs?
Mark, hard hitting question.
Did you steal wearing
the same thing every day
from Steve Jobs?
- I don't think so.
I just think I was maybe a little lazy
and then had some good
articulation of like, oh yeah,
this is just about saving mental energy.
But I think, I don't know.
It was never really a....
- You know what's funny Mark,
I'll be honest with you.
I actually think that's the punchline.
You consciously or
subconsciously made that decision
to represent yourself.
And I think that going digital
is going to be extraordinary.
I really do.
I really think that people
are grossly underestimating
that almost all the
things we've been doing
are about to get more
visual, more collateralized,
more obvious.
I don't think a lot of people realize
why they bought a Rolex.
I really don't.
I don't think a lot of people realize.
I don't think I overthink
why, at 45 years old,
I look like I'm 13 right now.
There's a lot going on in that.
And I think that when it hits digital,
it becomes more obvious.
I think a lot of people's conversation
about what's going on on digital
is actually just showing us what we are
much more than anything else.
And so I think as we go into
the realm of consumerism
is insane, when you think
about how much people
buy things to communicate,
that going digital
and being so in our faces,
because so many of these
things sit in our homes
where 99% of our social
graph never sees it,
that going to a full 100 is fucking crazy.
- But I think you're hitting on a number
of important pieces here.
First, a lot of people think
about this as kind of commerce.
And I think a lot of it is
actually really expression,
which is the core social dynamics.
So the intersection
between that expression
and your identity, and then
the commerce around that,
especially if we can get
it to be interoperable
so it's a more fluid market,
I think is just going
to be a really big deal,
a much bigger than I think
people internalized today.
The other thing that I
think is really refreshing
and insightful to hear you talk about is
all the lessons from some
of the previous rounds
of development.
I hadn't really thought
before you raised it
about some of the early
Farmville experiences
or some of the stuff from a decade ago.
But I think you're right
that there is a clear through line,
both between the social
interactions that people have
and the types of commerce.
Obviously there's more technology now
that can make it more interoperable
and that can give people
more rights over the goods
that they have.
And on the AR and VR side,
making it so people can
feel a more realistic sense
of connection.
But I think you're right,
that a lot of these concepts
are not fundamentally new.
They're sort of the next
iteration on dynamics
that are evergreen and that
are just always going to be,
and always have been
very important to people
in terms of how we connect
and direct with each other.
- It's my take on what happened
when you were inventing.
I'm like, oh, people
put their kid's school
on their back of their windshield to flex.
My kid's going to Harvard
and might drop out.
That's what they would do.
We've been doing all these same things,
digital's just exposing
truths and scaling truths.
And I think the new
frontier of 3.0 metaverse
is going to take us to a
completely different place
that I do think Web 2.0
gave us a slight preview to.
- Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
- Mark, since we only have
a couple more minutes,
do you own any NFTs, have
you thought about buying any?
I feel like you're going more platforms.
Obviously, you as the
executive is platform side,
metaverse, that makes so much sense.
It's kind of like leapfrogging.
I understand that cold.
Especially the hardware-software dynamic
that I think you've been
through the last 15 years
makes all the sense to me in the world.
How about you, the human being?
Were you a collectors,
were you a comic book,
like did you collect as a kid?
- I was pretty into baseball cards.
So I had that, maybe a few comic books,
but more for entertainment
than collection.
The baseball cards, I
was really into that,
Especially baseball, I think
is really like the nerds game
'cause it's so.
- It's math.
You're a nerd, Mark.
- It's so mathematic.
- Shit, Mark, let's call a spade a spade.
But have you jumped into NFT land yet?
- I try to use all of this stuff.
- By the way, real quick,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
I know I've been, I'm excited.
I gotta give you this shout out
because this is back to the one thing
I've always connected with you on,
using all this stuff.
I don't know if you remember this,
but when Chatroulette came out,
which obviously had a 45 minutes cycle,
because at first it was brilliant,
and then it got weird real fast.
Literally the first night
I had multiple people
take screenshots because
I was early on fan pages
and you were on my fan page on Facebook
and people connected on interests
and you were literally there
and Facebook was already a real company
and you were like running a big company
and sure enough, at very
late into the night,
you are literally clicking
around meeting people randomly.
A, do you remember that?
- I feel like you gotta
use the stuff firsthand.
It's tough to just have
someone explain to you
or write a presentation
about what it's like.
I've had some pretty funny
experiences over the years
trying to use different social products.
Probably one of the
funnier ones I think is
at some point I decided that
I really need to understand
how dating apps worked .
At this point, I had been
dating Priscilla for a long time
or we may have even been married already.
So it was like, look,
Priscilla, just so you know,
I'm going to sign up for some dating apps
and we can do this together.
- Mark, somebody connecting
with the Zuck on Tinder
is the greatest thing
I could ever imagine.
- Well, I think I was on one,
I think it was called Coffee Meets bagel.
They give you one match a day.
And I got this match and
it was Priscilla's friend
and she was having dinner
with her the next night.
And I was like, all right.
Priscilla, just so you know,
like this came up, heads up.
But look, I just believe that
if you want to be in the game
building stuff, you really
should remain curious
and keep using all of this.
So yeah, on all the crypto work,
I try to be involved and experience that.
I think that there's a lot of
parts of the experience today
that are still pretty early.
I hesitate to say something
pejorative like broken,
because I think it's,
I have much more of the attitude of,
it's just not as great yet
as it will be in the future.
- That's for damn sure.
Some people, they look at
something and they're like,
oh, this isn't good.
But I think part of the
art of the whole thing
is just figuring out when
something is going to be awesome.
- Mark, they're not historians.
Of course, Web 3.0 doesn't
work as well as Web 2.0
15 years later.
Like shopping carts in 1996
took three minutes to buy something.
People forget that.
People forget the creech to
even get on the internet,
like people forget and
they're not historians.
And I think that's where they can learn.
Mark, thank you so much for your time.
I know you're busy.
I appreciate you being on the podcast.
- Happy to do it.
All right, catch you soon.